for the police this has been a long and
complex operation trying to clear
London's main roads of protesters
pushing them up to Trafalgar Square at
the end of this first week they have
largely succeeded in that objective 202
203 204 could they be directed to go to
Birdcage Walk but the ground commander
in charge of coordinating multiple
police teams knows that control could be
lost at any moment it has been a game of
cat and mouse all week so in terms
across the rest of the sector the
bridges are all yeah here in Trafalgar
Square it's almost like a Police honor
guard as the Harris which has blocked
the road way for days is finally removed
and now there's this structure to
dismantle far from easy with protesters
chained to it
so this show can look like some of the
issues you have when it sort people say
why are you just playing the roads this
is some of the challenges we face around
sophisticated strategies are you've got
some cops around at the moment who will
just do the protection but to make sure
that no-one else looks on and then
they'll start working very slowly to get
that indeed this was a painfully slow
process as these specialist officers
carefully cut the protesters free as
that operation continued the commanders
next job serving hundreds of protesters
came to nearby sin James's Park with
public order notices to move or face
arrest be very obvious what we're doing
no surprise about all would be lovely if
you would coming to the local area for
ID for the police now it's about holding
the areas they've cleared and responding
to any more pop-up protests like this
one outside the BBC today but as this
shows it's often impossible to stay one
step ahead of the activists back in
Trafalgar Square it was close to three
hours before all of those on this
makeshift Tower were cut free and
arrested
this is a huge strain on police
resources which will continue for
another week many more days of trying to
second-guess extinction rebellions next
move mark white sky leaves
[Applause]